lá botar todos ou ficar calados ou
integral no estado da bahia e hoje
viemos aqui falar sobre o crescimento
sustentável dos oceanos como estão
dizendo nacional e acima de tudo um
desafio global
todos temos que encarar e egito para
conforto
eu soube ópera em profissão e gosto de
ver as pessoas sobre o américa veio a
reação delas invariavelmente eu tenho
umas duas criações
a primeira é pagar o benefício é muito
difícil estar aqui
a segunda reação é é fabio pinto que não
sabe se é um caso estranho porque para
ganhar mais distraído 97% nosso
território está debaixo d'água
portugal é mais o melhor para ele
lançado no país em 97% é água
acima de tudo nós temos que ter
consciência portugal foi é e será sempre
um país tomado o nosso país adote um
manancial tempo nas décadas de costas
voltadas para o mar
viramos muito para o centro da europa
para bruxelas e viramos muitas portas
para o mar está na altura de ramos uma
volta e voltaram já aprovado e acima
tudo errado serzinho nacional que desde
sempre esteve conosco
mais do que isso é um desafio global
porque por que muito brevemente nós
vamos ser 9 bilhões de pessoas até 2050
o grande desafio que se coloca é um
desafio se tal é como é que nós vamos
alimentar 9 bilhões de pessoas 90
representa realmente a solução passa por
o uso sustentável dos oceanos passa por
uma pesca sustentável com uma cultura
sustentável pela diminuição das
agressões permanentes nós fazemos ao
associar you e acima de tudo eu ligar os
efeitos que a comissão tem vindo a ter
neste ecossistema ao longo destes anos
só que alguns dados gerais pré venda
mais distraído
quatro em cada cinco formas de vida que
nós conhecemos estão nos oceanos
metade do oxigênio nós respiramos é
produzido nos oceanos
aproximadamente metade da população
mundial vive é menos 100 quilômetros da
costa
nossa imagina em opção que representa
para as propostas temas
pior que isso anualmente sobre os barcos
para nós seres humanos 15 bilhões de
euros em países que apanhar forma ilegal
ou não chorava e mais nosso braço dos
toques país que neste momento colapsaram
passou em fazer as paradas do colapso
isso representaria um retorno anual de
35 milhões de euros
portanto para quem é mais estreito ainda
acha que temos tempo para fazer alguma
coisa que eu estou dizer e leva essa
pessoa passa o natal em que lina planeta
dela porque aumenta lançado por
encerrado
nós não temos margem de manobra e temos
que exigir agora alguns exemplos mais ou
menos dramáticos e pescante um super a
questão
cusack terreiro tem capacidade para
conter que aviões jumbo
imagine só a dimensão dessa embarcação
uma das telhas nós vamos fazer deste já
é deixar ficar como se não houvesse
amanhã
nós temos que buscar assim para haver
uma manhã
a única peça que podem ter subsidiado e
pesca sustentável e não esta festa
industrial desenfreada que acima de tudo
louco lado dos principais tópicos de
todo mundo
como diz um outro colega brincar se os
gestores tóxicos fossem estes estatutos
preço que os toques lotaram todos
portanto o que nós temos de ir acima de
tudo é complicado nós consumidores nós
compramos sejam aplicados em
certificados e que existam seu convidado
e de sustentabilidade associado
explicada como por exemplo nós temos
carência de língua portuguesa foi a
primeira vez que queria ser certificada
pelo iso tipo causam portanto não é
impossível de ser realizado ainda
acontecer a uma provocação
quando você já foram ao restaurante
japonês saborear voz a china alertou que
eu também gosto muito e questionaram se
aquilo tenha sido apanhado fora local
aproximadamente
enquanto pedras assassinado a nível
mundial resulta de pesca ilegal e o ato
é uma das espécies onde os estoques
estão praticamente a psa como deus até
já começaram e nós brigamos selecionar
apenas tenha sido apanhado de acordo com
normas pré-estabelecidas e tenha sido
certificado mesma coisa se aplica ao
nosso fiel amigo
todos nós sabemos que essa é uma paixão
por vai pegar o nosso dos fundos maiores
consumidores per capita mundiais país
conseguimos apaixonada menos 60
quilogramas faz por ano e acima tudo
está pescoço é bacalhau
portanto nós temos que ter consciência
que algo tem que mudar tem que cuidar do
rendimento e como espécie que estão a
passar nos tem se dito é que o futuro
vai ser a cultura efetivamente das
pescas da última década
nosso viram nós estamos a atingir até
atingir 18 vai aumentar a capacidade
máxima festa e moacir a qual é o
problema aumentar a produção em
aquacultura é companheiro está errada
nós continuamos a depender de farinha de
peixe além do país para fazer para isso
obviamente que isto faça opinião a um
nicho municípios que é calculado que o
fifteen fechar para saber quanto de
outro país é capaz de testar para ver se
ele vai chegar à cultura e assim eles
têm que ser inferior ão isso nós já
vamos nós vemos por exemplo salmão
robalo dourada o próprio cameron e os
que estamos consumir tem filhos superior
ão os pais têm um filho inferior ão são
quase todas as partes de água dos rios
no entanto a cultura da água doce também
tem alguns problemas que eu ia falar
mais à frente nomeadamente o facto
agradou ser um país bonito e que faz
falta para os consumos das populações
no entanto isso tem tudo está errado na
cultura nós olharmos para a quantidade
que você faz podemos produzir por sem
demonstração nós podemos produzir muito
mais país com a mesma qualidade da ração
do conselho discutir fry o corpo
nós temos que mudar um paradigma dos
ingredientes nós vamos perfurar essas
canções
temos que utilizar fontes próprias
alternativas sejam elas macroalgas
microalgas seja proteína de insetos seja
proteger
blusas o que a empresa já não podem
continuar a haver essa necessidade de
apanhar país para fazer parte de cima
tudo não podemos continuar a utilizar a
proteína de proteína de soja essa faz
falta para orientar as pessoas e não ter
desviado do consumo mais para a produção
de rações é a cultura aqui mais alguns
exemplos têm preciso ter em consideração
que ele cidade e aproveitar todos os
nutrientes que são injetados no sistema
produção em aquacultura
nós damos uma ração para alimentar
nossos animais no nosso país nós
camarões pois temos que ter preocupação
de aproveitar os nutrientes não são
indiferentes a opção de poder estar de
preços animais utilizar microalgas
utilizar de vals utilizar animais possam
o quantas possam alimentar dessas peças
dessas partículas que não sejam
disponibilizadas para o meio ambiente
mostra que uma imagem do bairro até as
duas do sal
para ilustrar a problemática da cultura
em agosto mas na cultura mundial é
realizada na china uma parte muito
significativa em produção em água doce
pra comer muita diferença se há vítimas
por exemplo vai colher essas pessoas
tenham na torcida - 4 de agosto para
todos e camarão e isso tem um fato é que
as pessoas utilizem água são obra para
produzir acabaram está na ação
indenização escreve tornados foi
completamente desadequados para que
volta a ser possível produzir arroz
nesses cargos e acima tudo faz com que
muitas populações tenham se deslocar
zina que lances de alimento em busca de
água potável ou seja há uma problemática
urgente que é necessário controlado
desenvolver nomeadamente a cultura assim
é uma opção mas tem que ser uma cultura
sustentável que sendo um paradigma
diferente da que teve até agora por
alguma razão nós vamos ficar nos animais
que não são um caminho que nós não
fazemos produção de tics milhões para o
consumo humano
o problema é que na maior parte das
vezes nós tentamos dormir na paz que tem
uma exigência que fazia lotada proteína
animal e temos que começar a reverter
esse paradigma é mais uma provocação
muitos de vocês já que nenhum país kato
é um país que tem entrado nos nossos
mercados o que queria mas vocês não
servia com o famoso peixe gato
o pagasa é um país está gostando
montanhas famosas a única 3 e é
produzido no local do serviço esse cara
está em comer essa faixa de 200 do
mekong no vietnã que é só um dos rituais
mais poluídos todo mundo
nós em portugal temos um preconceito
muito grande com tropas da cultura
o chamado global tiveram adorada de
israel
então eles são meus amigos ou acha que o
salvam que nós criamos essa moça
salvagem escapou das garras duas
o salão nós conseguimos aqui é total na
cultura
por trás dessa questão do preconceito
para com o país a cultura é bastante
interessante e acima de tudo do ponto de
vista da segurança alimentar é
muitíssimo mais curto como um país a
cultura da competição fazem essa imagem
da nossa ria da vai-vai nós produzimos
roubar autor a da língua de forma semi
intensiva
erros trabalho que o que eu acho que em
relação ao país que nós temos aqui na
nossa via é um país que nós meus filhos
se não tivesse confiança nesse país
cópia nunca faria é um preço ponderado
superior e tem que ser diferenciado do
restante buscado nós compramos porque é
um país produtivo de forma sustentada e
acima de tudo ajuda a manter o
patrimônio cultural e social desta com
sistema que nós temos
outro que está muito importante tem que
ver com as nossas riquezas e joão
mineral e também envolve hidrocarbonetos
nós com essa missão da extensão da
plataforma continental
este é o nosso grande drama só pra ter
uma noção dos montantes que estão
envolvidos estima se que cada pessoa
existem no fundo óssea quatro quilos de
ouro
bora lá vá procurar ouro porque está
muito funk tá gostando muito de repente
foi irado mas esta questão é muito os
zetas o vento nós estamos a trabalhar
com pessoas estrelas
quer dizer que os poluentes nos
comportar da mesma maneira e para quem
anda mais treinou mais esquecido nem por
isso que aconteceu no golfo do méxico na
plataforma dpp 700 mil metros cúbicos de
crude foi chamado quando é que o google
mal porque o tão mal a ninguém
como é que eu conheço alvinegro dias o
grupo continua o churrasco do fundo do
oceano
nunca ninguém se lembrará tudo o que
queria fazer
se por acaso acontecer isso que vai
acontecer outra coisa muito importante
nós temos que ter atenção nas nossas
águas é um problema da biopirataria
os recursos técnicos que nós temos no
fundo dos nossos oceanos em habitar
extremos como por exemplo quanto a ter
mais
nós temos que o usuário para que o
banqueiro modo que é de todos enquanto
isso a nokia não passa apenas a ceder
alguns o potencial instalado em
particular talks fala-se de novos
produtos de valor acrescentado é muito
muito elevado mas isso valor
acrescentado tantas bandeiras favor do
povo português e não apenas - e travas
elétricas conhecimento gera
desenvolvimento desenvolvimento gera
riqueza uma versão que não tenha
conhecimento será sempre uma nação pobre
portanto tirar dinheiro às universidades
e os institutos não é um tiro no pé é o
que nos dois pés e um tiro na cabeça
outra coisa muito interessante um
documento que todos os portugueses
deveriam conhecer a estratégia nacional
para o mar
costumo dizer que quem não sabe para
onde vai
nenhum evento é favorável a uma nova
impressora de uma estratégia bastante
racional foi posta em consulta pública
para que as pessoas bem a sua opinião
neste momento há uma pesquisa pela
primeira vez fazer um plano de longo
prazo como é que nós podemos
efetivamente gerir este nosso património
e acima de tudo garantir que não estamos
explorado é cheia dessas futuras nós
nunca tivemos em portugal uma geração
tão bem preparada a nível dos recursos
humanos
tecnicamente para podermos efetivamente
realizar o potencial que temos nas
nossas águas e se resigne nacional eu
nem vi tão cuidada e assim muito temos
deixar de pensar que estamos na cauda da
europa nós estamos na cauda da europa
nós estamos no centro oeste o céu
estratégico entre a europa áfrica e
américas portugal tem uma posição
privilegiada e temos essa grande
vantagem de ter 97% do nosso território
que é amado
a maior parte das pessoas ainda não viu
um novo mapa portanto
a casa coloquem no google portugal é mar
eo pocinho novo mapa evairton com grande
o vosso país
vamos conseguir claro que vamos
conseguir
afinal nós somos os heróis do mar nobre
povo nós já realizamos segunda feira na
volta por cima não é e por quem é que
vamos fazer essa regra está assim muito
nós temos que perceber que ninguém está
não dá conta de nós do que nós mesmos
não podemos estar à espera que foi
novamente fora ensinar aos portugueses
como é que temos que fazer as coisas em
nossa casa somos nós que seguimos o
nosso tempo
em portugal o nosso país e por quem é
que temos que fazer pra mim é muito
claro
temos que fazer porque elas são mais
sociais para nós porque nós sabemos que
merecem um futuro melhor do que o nosso
presente pra mim é particularmente mais
difícil porque eu sabia que o pai
arranja e como eu sou biólogo marinho
uma taxa legado vai ter que pensar
portanto vamos parar de treinar o barça
representarem a vida e acima de tudo eu
não quero ver os meus filhos
sabemos o que temos que fazer sabemos
como é que temos que fazer e acima de
tudo sabemos que não há tempo a perder
nós estamos a caminhar a passos largos
para um time que não tem retorno
por isso é que o que você quer perguntar
agora é dar o próximo passo
obrigado